yeah, I thought there would be negativity. I really did. I thought people would be like, how could you do that to C++? How could you betray, you know, WG21 like this? And that hasn't been the case at all. People from the committee have, you know, saw it before the launch.
是的，我原以为会招来负面评价，真的。我以为人们会说：“你怎么能对C++做出这种事？你怎么能背叛WG21（C++标准委员会）呢？”但事实完全不是这样。委员会里的人，你知道，在发布之前就看过了。
People have seen it since. They say, yeah, that might work for some problems. Because there are some problems, right? That are not tractable problems. Then it's another FAQ. Why don't you just improve C++? Like, well... Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 95, recorded on August 15th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we finish our four-part interview with Kate Gregory and talk to her about the carbon
发布之后大家也都看到了。他们会说：“好吧，这可能对解决某些问题有效，因为有些问题确实是难以解决的问题。”这就引出了另一个常见问题：为什么不直接改进C++呢？好吧……欢迎收听ADSP播客第95期，录制于2022年8月15日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联席主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，完成了对凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）的四部分系列采访的最后一部分，并与她探讨了碳（Carbon）编程语言。
programming language. So the conference went better than I could possibly have expected. The carbon launch also went very differently than I could have expected. A lot of the things I was really scared might've happened, did not happen. And a bunch of things happened that were fantastic that I was not expecting. So, you know, Chandler said in the keynote, join us. And people did. Very large numbers of people joined. And while some people were perhaps not offering constructive help and suggestions, a bunch of people really were. So, you know, from the very next day, there were people saying, hey, would a syntax highlighter for VS Code be helpful? I think I can do a Vim plugin. I think I can this. And people starting to discuss, I see you haven't
所以这次大会的进展比我预期的要好得多。Carbon的发布过程也和我预期的截然不同。我原本非常担心会发生的好多事情并没有发生，反而发生了一堆极其美妙且出乎意料的事情。所以，你知道的，钱德勒（Chandler）在主题演讲中说过：“加入我们吧。”人们确实加入了。数量极其庞大的人加入了进来。虽然有些人可能没有提供建设性的帮助和建议，但确实有一大批人提供了。所以，你知道，从第二天开始，就有人说：“嘿，VS Code的语法高亮插件会有用吗？我觉得我可以做一个Vim插件，我觉得我可以做这个。”人们开始讨论，我看到你们还没为比如lambda表达式之类的东西敲定设计。三四个人开始聚在一起，把这个细节推敲琢磨出来。事情正在取得进展。所以，一些在资源管理器（Explorer）中设计了但还没编写代码的东西，现在正在资源管理器中编写代码。有些事情正在取得进展。有些在资源管理器中设计但未编写代码的东西，正在资源管理器中编写代码。有些东西正在被设计。一些决定正在被做出。非常高兴。是的，我刚才特意查了一下。这是自发布以来。所以今天是8月15日。因此我们差不多正好发布了一个月，或者说刚不到一个月，我想，嗯……在GitHub上它有25.8千个星标，这相当了不起，而且已经有一千多个分支（fork）了。其实我不知道之前的具体数字是多少，但我猜那些数字应该……你知道的，要少得多，要么是个位数，要么是两位数。
settled the designs for, let's say, lambdas or something. Three or four people start getting together, hashing that out. Things are getting done. So some things that were designed but not coded in the Explorer are getting coded in the Explorer. Some things are getting done. So some things that were designed but not coded in the Explorer are getting coded in the Explorer. Some things are getting designed. Some decisions are getting made. Very happy. Yeah, I just went and pulled it up to see. It's since the launch. So today is August 15. So we're almost a month exactly out, just less than a month, I guess um on github it has 25.8 thousand stars which is pretty remarkable and already over a thousand forks i don't know actually what those were but i assume those were like you know less than you know either single digit or double digit numbers
在发布之前，只有几十个人参与。是的。当时有11个星标和……要么是11个星标和3个分支，要么是3个分支和11个星标，我记不清了，但我觉得可能反过来，发布前大概是3个星标和11个分支。我记得很清楚，因为我当时就在……
before we launched there were a few dozen people involved. Yeah. It was 11 stars and... It was either 11 stars and 3 forks or 3 forks and 11 stars, and I think it was probably the other way around, probably 3 stars and 11 forks before. I remember because I checked, right, as the
宣布消息的时候查过。是的，而且现在贡献者人数已经增加到了，我记得好像是87人左右。如果你看一下推送的代码量，就会发现——仅仅从他们几年前开始提交代码的情况来看——它在7月份这一个月里翻了四倍。所以很显然，过去的一个月里有非常多的活跃开发在进行。
announcement went out. Yeah, and it's up to I think it said 87 contributors or something. And if you look at the amount of code pushed, it has, just sort of looking at since they started commits over a couple years ago, looks like it quadrupled in the month of July. So clearly a lot of active development happening
是的，我本来想看看能不能查到Discord上有多少人，但我不知道该怎么做。总的来说，他们非常理解我们的氛围、行为准则以及我们试图做的事情。头几个星期，有很多重复的声音。有很多诸如“我搞不懂，这不就是Rust吗？为什么不直接用Rust？”这样的言论。而对这个问题的回答是：是的，如果你能用Rust，你完全应该用Rust。
in the last month here. Yeah, I was looking to see if I could figure out how many people were on the Discord, but I don't know how to do that. And by and large, they're very understanding of our atmosphere and our code of conduct and what we're trying to do. The first couple of weeks, there was a lot of repetition. There was a lot of like, I don't get it. It's just rust. Why not just use rust? And then the answer to that question is yes, if you can use rust, you should totally use rust.
就像这并不是它的竞争对手。如果Rust对你管用，那就用Rust。然后人们就会说：“好吧，你其实不是这个意思，这只是你随口说说而已。”不，不，不。那、那、那就是我的意思。紧接着，就涌现出了一堆高度重复的问题和建议，
Like this is not a competitor to that. If rust works for you, use rust. And then people like, well, you don't really mean that. That's just a thing you're saying. Nope. Nope. That that's, that's what I mean. And then, then there was a bunch of really repetitive questions and suggestions
而这些我们之前都已经处理过了。有数量庞大的人想要一个标志（Logo）。就像，我不……这大概和年龄有关。他们会说：“你们必须得有个标志。你们必须得有一个标志。如果没有标志，人们就不会严肃对待你们。我可以免费为你做一个标志。”不，我们不需要标志。“对，但你们应该”
that we'd already dealt with. Huge number of people wanting a logo. Like, I don't... This is an age thing. They're like, you have to have a logo. You have to have a logo. People won't take you seriously if you don't have a logo. I'll make you a logo for free. No, we don't have a logo. Yeah, but you should
有一个标志。“对，但我们还有更重要的事情要做。我们不想要标志。”我给你做一个。这种情况持续了一段时间。我的意思是，我个人非常喜欢……我的意思是，比如我大多数社交媒体账号上的横幅，不管是LinkedIn、Twitter还是YouTube，都只是一堆编程语言标志的集合。然而，我实际上并不觉得Carbon现在就需要一个标志，因为如果你看过钱德勒的主题演讲，这就好比……你知道的，他们目前仍然处于实验模式。
have a logo. Yeah, but we got bigger fish to fry. We don't want a logo. I'll make you one. And that went on for for some time. I mean, I personally love I mean, like the banners on most of my social media stuff, whether that's LinkedIn, or Twitter, or YouTube are just a collection of programming language logos. However, I don't actually feel like Carbon needs one yet because if you've watched Chandler's keynote, this is yet to be like, you know, they're in sort of still experiment mode.
我有这样一种感觉：如果过上六个月，在决策树里，某数量的决策已经被做出了——它看起来根本不像是会朝那个方向发展——但发布它的一部分原因并不像是……我们发布时的情形不像当年的Swift和苹果……在WWDC上发布时，这是Swift，这是我们的新语言，对吧？……Kotlin也是如此，这里是这门语言，我们希望你学习它，我们希望你开始使用它，这些工具支持它……而Carbon距离这一点还差得很远。
Like I get the feeling that like if in six months, a certain like in the decision tree, a certain number of decisions are taken. It doesn't seem like it's going in that direction at all but like a part of launching it it wasn't like we're launching and like when when swift and apple um were launched at a wwdc this was here is swift it's our new language right um and the same with kotlin right here's this language we want you to learn it we want you to start using it it's supported in these tools and and carbon is nowhere near want you to learn it. We want you to start using it. It's supported in these tools.
我们希望你学习它。我们希望你开始使用它。这些工具支持它。而Carbon距离这一点还差得十万八千里。你知道吗？是的，它还在1.0版本之前。尽管它看起来不像是在朝那个方向发展，我不知道该用什么词，比如资金被砍，或者被决定说“你知道，我们不需要这个”。
And carbon is nowhere near that. You know? Yeah, it's pre 1.0. And although it doesn't seem like it's going the direction that it would get, I don't know what the word is, defunded or decided that, you know, we don't need this.
它还在谷歌正式将其确立为目标之前。他们内部有一些这样的术语。尽管如此，也应该提一下，这并不是一个谷歌项目。只是它是由许多谷歌员工起步的。这类似于其他一些项目。我想Kubernetes就是其中之一，对吧？
It's before the point that Google has said, you know, this is one of our goals. Like they have some internal term. Although, and that shouldn't mention, it's not a Google project. It's just that it's starting out a lot of Google folks. It's similar to some other projects. Like I think Kubernetes is one of them, right?
它始于谷歌，但后来被放到了一艘小组织船上，漂向了大海。现在它不再由谷歌控制了。所以它拥有自己的基金会、自己的治理结构和自己的目标。你知道，因为部分问题在于——我们三个人以前也曾集体和个别地讨论过这一点——C++的委员会流程可能并没有很好地服务于这门语言，对吧？布莱斯，你曾说过你加入主要是为了获得MD Span，你还说那是多少年前的事了？对，花了七年时间。是的。
It started at Google, but then it got put on a little org boat and floated off into the sea. And now it's no longer controlled by Google. So you have its own foundation and its own governance and its own goals. You know, because part of the issue is, and the three of us have grouply and individually talked about this before, the committee process for C++ is perhaps not serving the language well, right? Bryce, you said you joined basically to get MD Span, and you said how many years ago that was? Yeah, it took seven years. Yeah.
你知道，并不是每个人都有毅力坚持七年。我的意思是，你知道，我的一个同事喜欢说，一门编程语言需要在某些方面比它的竞争对手好上10倍。好吧，我尚不知道Carbon在任何特定的技术方面是否比它的任何竞争对手好10倍，但在流程方面，它绝对比C++好10倍。我是这么认为的。
You know, not everybody would have had the gumption to stick with that for seven years. I mean, you know, one of my colleagues likes to say that a programming language needs to be 10x better than its competitors in some way. Well, I don't know yet whether Carbon is 10x better than any of its competitors on any particular technical aspect, but it's definitely 10x better than C++ in terms of process. I think so.
对我来说，流程和社区是极具吸引力的一部分。但也有人告诉我们，我们太天真了，等我们想进入顶级联赛并获得各大编译器厂商的支持等等时，我们就会发现采用
The process and the community is a big part of the appeal for me. But there are people who tell us that we're naive and that when we want to play in the big leagues and get support from major compiler vendors and blah, blah, that we'll discover the advantages
不同流程的优势。我不这么认为。我认为这是一个能够扩展并加以利用的流程，特别是有了领导层（leads）结构之后。所以我们不必总是在，你知道的，一万个随机陌生人中进行投票，其中有些人投票只是因为他们觉得好玩。
of a different process. I don't think so. I think this is a process that can scale and can be leveraged, especially with the leads structure. So we're not always voting amongst, you know, 10,000 random strangers, some of whom would just vote for Bodie McBoatface because they think it's funny.
是的。我的意思是，随着语言的发展，Carbon的流程肯定也会随之演变，这是毋庸置疑的。但流程本身能够演变这一事实，相比C++的流程就是一个巨大的改进。我是这么认为的。我也非常、非常兴奋于能够刻意拒绝向后兼容。你只是在说：我们可能会以某种破坏你代码的方式来改变语言，而当我们这样做时，我们会发布一个能够迁移你代码的工具，但我们不会永远死守着“既然1972年就是这样，所以它就永远不能改变”的教条，对吧？所以我的意思是，
Yeah. I mean, certainly it's probably true that the carbon process will evolve as the language evolves. But the fact that the process can evolve in and of itself is a huge improvement over the C++ process. I think so. I'm also very, very excited about deliberately rejecting backwards compatibility. You're just saying, like, we might change the language in a way that breaks your code and when we do that we will release a tool that will migrate your code but we're not just going to forever stick to well this was how it was in 1972 and so it can never change right so i mean
关于我们C++中所有的默认设置都是错的这个笑话，并不是一个笑话。这是事实。我们所有的默认设置都是错的，因为这门语言是按照某种特定方式编写的，然后人们说：“这可能是错的。我们应该拥有这种其他功能。”但我们不得不让旧代码依然能够运行。比如，构造函数的explicit（显式）关键字。你必须声明，如果你什么都不写——不能打破你的旧代码，就不能说所有构造函数都是显式的。但在Carbon中，我们可以。我们可以说：我们以前错了。
the joke about all our defaults being wrong in c++ is not a joke. It's the truth. All our defaults are wrong because the language was written a certain way, and then people said, that might be wrong. We should have this other capability, but we had to make old codes still work. So, like, explicit for constructors. That you have to say, if you don't say anything, can't break your old code, can't say all constructors are explicit. But in Carbon, we could. We could say, we were wrong.
除非你将其标记为隐式（implicit），否则所有构造函数都是显式的。然后我们会给你提供一个工具，它会遍历你的代码，找出你所有的构造函数并将它们标记为隐式。我很惊讶听到你从某些人那里听说，当Carbon迈向你所说的顶级联赛时，他们会发现这种流程行不通，因为这难道不是已经某种程度上被证明了吗？——倒不是说Carbon的流程和Swift、Rust或任何其他语言完全一样——但这是一个已被证明的模式：你不需要成为一个ISO……或者我不确定他们具体是怎么说的，就像你会发现C++正在做的事情是对的……但总的来说，至少从我听到的情况来看，
All constructors are explicit unless you mark them implicit. And then we'd give you a tool that would go through your code and find all your constructors and mark them implicit. I'm surprised to hear that you heard from certain folks that when Carbon took some step into what you mentioned is the big leagues that they would discover the process wouldn't work because isn't it already sort of proven like not that Carbon's process is identical to Swift's or Russ or any number of languages but like it's it's proven model that you don't need to be an ice or i'm not sure exactly what they were saying like you'll discover that what c++ is doing right but like it seems like in general at least from what i've heard that like
C++并不是现代流程的典范，比如演进语言。因此有一整系列的语言都在说：这太慢了，太官僚了，太排他了。这就像是有很强的把关人机制，你知道的？是的。如果你飞不到夏威夷，你就不能投票。
c++ is not like the model of modern process like evolving languages. So there's a whole series of languages that say that's too slow, too corporate, too exclusive. Like it's very gatekeepy, you know? Yeah. If you can't fly to Hawaii, you can't vote.
是的。你知道，如今说出这一点很难，特别是经历了疫情之后，人们会说：“不，我们理应都能加入一个Zoom通话，我们理应都是平等的。”你知道，“我们理应都是同行。”
Yeah. You know, that's a hard, that's a hard thing to say these days, especially after the pandemic, people are like, no, we should all be able to get in a zoom call and we should all be equivalent. You know, we should all be peers.
但是，你知道，也许有些东西很难扩展。也许保密性在某些地方也有其价值。保持超级开放和超级透明可能会把某些人拒之门外。我不知道。我们走着瞧。我们不必成为适合所有人的编程语言。我们只需要成为一门优秀的编程语言。是的。我很惊讶听到这是你的所闻，因为如果说有什么不同的话，我认为现代语言都在某种程度上顺应了这一趋势，它们都有在线讨论和在线决策的方式。
But, you know, maybe some things are hard to scale. Maybe secrecy has some value in some places. Being super open and super transparent maybe would keep some people away. I don't know. We'll see. We don't have to be the programming language for everybody. We just have to be a good programming language. Yeah. I'm surprised to hear that that's what you've heard because, if anything, I think that most modern languages are all sort of following suit, that they've got ways to discuss things online
这并不是说ISO一无是处。ISO绝对有它的优势。但是，特别是当你记住我们在本播客中提出的一些事情时。布莱斯当时是怎么评论的，你知道的，某些国家的签证等待时间？我想你当时说的是印度，对吧？有一次你查了一下，发现需要700多天。然后当你重新查的时候，是300多天还是什么的。所以这就好像，好吧，你知道，取决于你什么时候查，
and make decisions online. And not to say that there's nothing good about ISO. There's definitely advantages to ISO. But yeah, especially like when you keep in mind some of the things that we've brought up on this podcast. What did Bryce remark that, you know, the visa wait times for certain countries? I think you were talking about was it India at that one point? And it was like you checked at one time and it was like 700 plus days. And then when you rechecked, it was 300 or something. And so it's like, well, you know, depending on when you check, you know,
你也许能去，也许不是明年，而是两年后。这就好比，这些委员会会议每三个月举行一次，或者至少在疫情爆发之前是这样的。而且，这纯粹是时间问题。这就好比，我需要签证才能去中国，我极少需要签证去其他任何地方。你知道，他们会问诸如“列出你过去10去过的所有地方，过去10年里你在非自己家里的任何地方睡过觉的所有地方”。要一个人提供这些信息，甚至哪怕只是把它们写下来（如果他们恰好知道的话），这也是个不小的要求，你知道吗？而且资金成本也不容忽视。学者们告诉我，申请签证可能要花一千美元。这是一大笔钱。我们刚才还谈到研究生赚的钱有多么微薄，你知道吗？
you might be able to go maybe not next year, but like two years from now. And it's like, well, these committee meetings happen once every three months, or at least they did when before the pandemic took place. And it's, uh, and it's just the time. It's like, so I needed a visa to go to China, I very rarely need a visa to go anywhere. And you know, they say things like list everywhere you've been for the last 10 years, everywhere you slept a night that wasn't your home for the last 10 years. That's a lot to ask a person to produce that information or to even to write it up if they happen to know it, you know? And I think that the money is non-trivial either. Academics tell me that it can cost a thousand dollars to apply for a visa. That's a lot of money. We just talked about how little money
是的。我的意思是，是的。然后你会听说，参会差旅只有250美元的津贴之类的，然后就会觉得：“哦，好吧，这确实有帮助，嗯，这大概够付一晚上的酒店费用吧。”是的，是的。所以我理解聚在一个房间里的价值，过去一段时间我真的很想念它，而且能够通过面对面的会议重新回归这种状态，我真的非常非常高兴。我知道混合会议（hybrid）很昂贵，就像，你知道的，我们举办CPP North时就没有搞混合模式。很多人一直在说：“每个会议都应该是混合模式的。不这样做就是侵犯人权。”而我想：“哦，我一定是漏掉了你给我赞助资金来举办混合会议的那一部分。”因为这真的是一件非常昂贵的事情，对吧？我只是……我真的很想让每个人都能参与其中，真的。
graduate students make, you know? Yeah. I mean, yeah. And then you'll hear about the, there's a $250 stipend for conference travels and stuff and it's like oh well that is helpful yeah that covers one night of hotel maybe yeah yeah so i understand the value of being in a room together um i've really missed it over the last little while and i was very very happy to get back to it with in-person conferences uh and i know that hybrid is expensive like Like, you know, we didn't run CPP North hybrid. And a lot of people have been like, every conference should be hybrid. It's, it's a violation of, you know, human rights, not, and I'm like, oh, I must have missed the part
是的，无障碍性——我的意思是，我们以前也提到过这一点——我们非常希望在未来获得赞助时，能为我们所有的每一集节目提供文字记录（transcripts）。我的另一个播客确实有文字记录，但所花费的时间……而且它并不完全是……实际上，我不确定他们是否花钱，但你可以付费购买文字记录。不过这目前并不是一件便宜的事情，嗯，许多服务都是按分钟计费的，所以如果你有长达一小时的播客，加起来总共就是……你知道的，每年几千美元，而且……是的，更重要的是，这需要时间，确实耗费大量精力。就像，嗯，Pluralsight的课程，它们几乎会立即推出机器生成的文字记录，但这基本没什么用。然后在几天或几周后，会有专人去对文字记录进行编辑，接着它就变得非常棒了。我经常使用它，因为有人会问：“你能给我解释一下什么什么吗？”然后我就会进入我自己的课程，调出文字记录，搜索那个词。接着我就能找到那个解释，它还会链接到剪辑中的精确时间点。然后我就能说：“哦，当然。”
where you're giving me the money to run the hybrid conference. Cause it's like very expensive thing to do. Right. I just, I would love to make everything accessible to everybody. I would. Yeah. Accessibility is, I mean, we've mentioned that before is that we would love to, at some point when we get sponsored for it, we will love to have transcripts for all of our episodes. And my other podcast does do transcripts, but the amount of time, and it's not completely, actually, I'm not sure if they spend money but like you can get you can pay for transcripts um but it is currently not a cheap thing to do like um a lot of them are by the minute so if you have hour-long podcasts um that totals up to you know a couple
“在第七模块第二个剪辑的一分钟处，你就会看到。”我不知道，也许他们以为我把整门课程都背下来了，其实我只是在搜索文字记录，你知道的。这真是一个绝佳的技巧，不仅适用于查找课程资料，在每个YouTube视频上，它们都有自动生成的文字记录，你也可以完全如法炮制。如果我什么时候想找引言——无论是凯特说的，还是肖恩（Sean）或其他什么人的——你只需打开文字记录，搜索“rotate”，然后点击几次“下一个、下一个”，就能找到引言。
thousand dollars a year and um yeah and and more more importantly it's it's time like it does take a lot of time so like uh with the pluralsight courses, they come out almost immediately with a machine generated transcript, which is basically useless. And then some number of days or weeks later, a human has gone through and edited that transcript and then it's great. And I use it all the time because someone will say, could you explain whatever to me? And I'll go into my own course, bring up the transcript, search for that word. And then I can find that explanation. Then it links back to the exact moment in the clip. And I'm like, oh, sure.
然后点击该片段并播放。太棒了。我的意思是，这就是所谓的“坡道切口”（curb cut）效应，对吧？你做某事是为了帮助一个群体，但结果却帮到了成千上万的人。我发现……你可能应该解释一下什么是坡道切口。我甚至不住在城里，但我以前住在城里。如果有一个马路牙子（curb），也就是路边凸起的一小块水泥，
In module seven, clip two, at the one minute time mark, you will see. And I don't know, maybe they think I have the whole course memorized. I'm just searching the transcript, you know. That is a great hack, not just for looking up course stuff, but like on every YouTube video, they have transcripts automatically generated and you can do the exact same thing. If I'm ever looking for quotes from whether it's Kate or, you know, Sean or someone, you can just open up the transcript, search for rotate and then go and click next, next a couple of times and find a quote.
坐轮椅从上面颠下去既不舒服又困难，而要推上去可能根本不可能。所以你会让人在那里切出一个缺口，这样从马路到人行道就有一个平缓的入口。但事实证明，这不仅能帮助坐轮椅的人和使用助行器的人，还能帮助推婴儿车的、推着满载货物的平板手推车去送货的人，诸如此类。而且，受益于这种无障碍设施的所谓“健全人”，其数量可能达到了你为之证明其合理性的残疾人群体的10倍之多。
And then click to that bit and play it. It's fantastic. I mean, this is the whole curb cut thing, right? You do something to help one group, but it turns out to help a ton of people. And I found... You should probably explain what curb cuts are. So I don't even live in the city, but I used to live in the city. And if there's a curb, a little piece of raised cement at the edge of the road,
闭幕字幕也是如此。人们会说：“有多少听不见声音的人会来参加会议？”首先，比你想象的要多，因为我儿子在一家助听器公司工作。当我提到这一点时，人们纷纷告诉我他们戴着助听器。这就好像：“我无法告诉你这种情况发生过多少次。”人们会说：“哦，我戴着助听器。”而且他们平时不会主动告诉你。所以有相当多的人在听力方面需要一些帮助。但也有人有足够的勇气去参加一场使用他们第二语言（我做梦都不敢这样做）或第五语言的会议，书面材料能帮助他们理解听到的内容，或者演讲者带有一定的口音，而书面材料也能提供帮助。所以有太多事情，我们起初是为那些我们心生怜悯、觉得必须帮助的某种特定状况的人做的，但结果证明，它对另外一大批人其实更有用。如果你对某种食物过敏，公布菜单也会非常有用。但它对其他所有人也都超级有用。
to bump down that in a wheelchair is uncomfortable and difficult, and to bump up it may be impossible. So you get them to cut a gap there so that there's a smooth entrance from the road up to the sidewalk. But it turns out that it helps not just people in wheelchairs and people with walkers, but people who are pushing strollers and people who are wheeling dollies full of something they're delivering and what have you. And that perhaps 10 times as many, quote unquote, able-bodied people benefit from the accommodation as the people that you justified doing it for.
是的，甚至连那些人……是的，完全四肢健全的人。就像你刚才谈到坡道切口时，我在想，肯定有一定比例的人，他们本来跨过那个台阶没有任何问题，但只是……只是你知道的，10%的人偶尔会因为台阶稍微高了一点而被绊倒，而这能减少绊倒的人数；或者如果你有行李，如果你有手提箱……是的，是的，我的意思是……事实证明，正如他们所说，如果你现在没有残疾，那其实只是说明你还没残疾罢了，对吧？在某个时候，也许你会摔断胳膊，手臂打上几周石膏，那时你会非常感谢那些可以用手肘去按开门的按钮。有一栋公寓楼我经常去，那里有自动开门器，但通往楼梯的门却没有。其他所有地方都有自动开门器，而他们却觉得：“如果你能走楼梯上楼，你就能自己开门。”而我认为，事情根本不是这样的。很多人能走楼梯上楼，但他们就是打不开门。你应该在所有的门上都装上自动开门器，对吧？因为……因为这不仅仅是你需要适应的一种差异……
And so the same with closed captioning. People say, well, how many people come to a conference who can't hear? Well, first of all, more than you'd think, because my son works for a hearing aid company. And when I mentioned that, people tell me they wear hearing aids. It's like, I can't tell you how many times that's happened to me. People say, Oh, I wear hearing aids. And they won't tell you otherwise. So there's an awful lot of people who could use some help when it comes to hearing. But there are also people who are brave enough to go to a conference in their second language, which I would never dream of doing, or their fifth, and the written material helps them to understand what they're hearing, or the speaker has a bit of an accent and the written
对，对。我也很喜欢疫情后出现的新式挥手感应开门器，没错，你甚至都不用去按它们。其一，是的。我不是洁癖，但不用去按它们感觉确实更好。其二，它们也更方便。这就好比，当你提着杂货或其他什么东西时，有一半的时间……
material helps. So there's so many things that we do them for people with a condition that we sort of feel sorry for and we have to help them, but it turns out it's actually more useful to this huge other chunk of folk. And publishing the menus is very useful if you can't eat a particular food. But it was super useful for everyone else. Yeah, even even folks. Yeah, completely able bodied. Like when you were talking about the curb cutting is I was thinking I'm sure there's like a percentage of people that have no problems with, you know, taking that step up that just, that just you know 10 of people trip every once in a while because there's a little higher and it's just less people are tripping or or if you have if you have luggage if you have suitcases yeah yeah i mean there's and it turns out like
你需要努力把手肘抬起来去按。而现在，你只需要把杂货袋在它前面一挥，砰，就可以直接通过了。是的。有太多事情，你知道的，在疫情之前是完全不可能的：“不，你不能在线订购那个。”“不，我们不能通过Zoom开会。”
they say that if you're if you're not disabled you're really just not disabled yet right at some point maybe you'll break your arm and you'll have your arm in a cast for some number of weeks and you'll be very glad of those buttons that you can hit with your elbow to open the door there's an apartment building that I go to a lot and it has automatic door openers but not at the door that has stairs up to it everywhere else there's automatic door openers and they're like no if you can walk upstairs you can open a door and I'm like that's not that's not how this works lots of people can walk up the stairs but they can't open the door you should have automatic door openers on all your doors right because because it's there's more than just one uh difference that you that you
是的，有太多事情，你知道的，在疫情之前是完全不可能的：“不，你不能在线订购那个。”“不，我们不能通过Zoom开会。”“你必须开车三个小时来开会。”“你必须坐飞机来开会。”而我们发现，实际上这完全是可行的。或者就像……现在到处都可以刷信用卡了，这是我最喜欢的。
need to accommodate yeah yeah i love the new post-pandemic hand wave door openers now too that's right you don't even need to hit them. One, yeah. I'm not a germaphobe, but like, it's just nicer not to be able to have to. But two, they're also just easier. It's like, it's half the time when you're carrying groceries or whatever. Yeah. And you need to try and get your elbow up.
是的，再也不用到处带现金了。我都不记得我上一次用现金买东西是什么时候了。是的，全都是信用卡和借记卡。还有那本书，《精美C++》（Beautiful C++），盖伊（Guy）就是在他的上下班通勤时间里写完那本书的。哇。
And it's like, now you can just wave the grocery bag in front of it and poof, you're good to go. Yes. Yeah. There's so many things that, you know, were completely impossible before the pandemic. No, you can't order that online. No, we can't meet over Zoom. yeah there's so many things that you know were completely impossible before the pandemic no you can't order that online no we can't meet over zoom you have to drive three hours in to have the meeting you have to fly for the meeting we found out actually it's quite possible or or like uh everywhere everywhere takes credit cards now that's that's my favorite
他单程通勤要45分钟。我想大概是这个数字。所以当他在疫情期间在家办公时，每天多出了一个半小时。他所做的是，在他平时通常会去上班的时间，他去写书。所以当他在疫情期间在家办公时，他每天多出了一个半小时。他所做的是，在他平时本该去上班的时间，他去写书，一直写到9点钟。然后他合上电脑，开始整天的工作。下午5点本该是他开车回家的时候，他又接着写书。
yes to bring cash anywhere i i can't remember the last time I used cash for anything. Yeah. It's just all credit and debit. And you know, the book, Beautiful C++, Guy wrote that book in his commute time. Wow. He had 45 minutes each way commute. I think that's the number. So when he was working from home during the pandemic, an extra hour and a half a day.
是的，我一直……其实我再也不需要通勤了，但以前要通勤的时候，我非常喜欢这段时间，因为我可以读很多书。我现在听更多有声书了，但那时候多伦多公共图书馆简直太棒了。
And what he did is, at the time he would have normally gone to work, he went and worked on the number. So when he was working from home during the pandemic, he had an extra hour and a half a day. And what he did is at the time he would have normally gone to work, he went and worked on the book until nine o'clock. Then he closed that, worked on work all day. Five o'clock when he would have been driving home, he worked on the book. Yeah, it's, I've always never really, I mean, I don't commute anymore, but when I used to, I used to love it because I would read so much. I do more audio books now, but back then the Toronto Public Library is just fantastic.
而且他们有……虽然我好几年没用了……但他们有一个惊人的预约系统，你可以把书加入保留队列，然后暂停保留，在队列里慢慢往前排。所以当你在……不管怎样，这真的很棒。加拿大的……我的意思是，我不该说是加拿大的，具体来说是多伦多的那个。是的，单程只要20或25分钟，来回就是50分钟。如果人们只是在手机上玩《糖果粉碎传奇》（Candy Crush）之类的，也许会觉得有点烦人。
And they've got, I haven't used it in years, but they've got an amazing reservation system where you can put books on hold and then like pause the on hold and you work your way up a queue. So like when you're at the, anyway, it's great. Canadian, I mean, I shouldn't say Canadian. It's specifically the Toronto one. And yeah, like with just 20 or 25 minutes each way, it's 50 minutes. And if folks are just whatever, playing Candy Crush on their phone, maybe it's kind of irritating.
但如果你在消费内容或者保持高效，这就好像是一段超棒的零碎时间，而你很难……这就好比，要找到50分钟，或者每天两次25分钟的时间有多难呢？但一旦这种由通勤带来的必需性消失了，你就再也不会主动去选择它了。人们会说：“哦，你既然就在那儿，那我可以直接问你一个问题。”
But if you're consuming or being productive, it's like an awesome little chunk of time that it's kind of hard. It's like, oh, how hard is it to find 50 minutes or 25 times 2 slots a day but like as soon as it's not there by necessity it's just kind of you never are in the routine of like choosing it you know people can say oh you're right there so I can just ask you a question
“我可以直接问你，我可以随时打断你，或者也许我可以多睡半小时，或者也许我可以……我可以顺便去跑个腿，诸如此类。”是的，是的，是的。我很久没在真正的办公室工作过了，但我以前经常去客户的办公室开会。是的，这挺好的。我想我已经说过好几次了，如果在完全远程和完全面谈之间做出选择，我认为远程会100%胜出，因为灵活性太高了，而且它……无论如何，我们刚才在谈论Carbon，对吧？……然后……
I can just ask you I can just interrupt you or maybe I could sleep for another half an hour or maybe I could have I could take care of half an hour or maybe I could have uh I could take care of that errand or whatever yeah yeah yeah it's I I haven't worked in an office for a real long time but I used to go to to clients offices and go to to meetings yeah it's good i think i've said this a couple times but having to choose between either fully remote or fully in person like it would i think remote would win 100 of the time because there's just too much flexibility and it's um anyways we were talking about carbon yeah uh and then and
然后我们聊偏了。Carbon是完全远程的吗？它完全是在线的，而且完全公开透明。没有什么秘密会议闭门造车然后出来宣布：“好吧，这就是我们要做的决定。”一切都是公开的。偶尔会有领导层必须做出决定的时候，但这种情况通常都发生在其他人也在场的通话中。对。作为最后一个问题，可能也是我们最后一次快要结束时的收尾，因为你既参与Carbon多年，又在C++领域工作多年。
then we got sidetracked carbon is all remote? It's all online and it's all open and transparent. There's no secret meeting that comes back and says, well, this is what we're going to do. Everything's open. Every once in a while, there's things that the leads will have to decide, but it's quite common for that to happen on a call that other people are on. Right. And maybe as one sort of like last final question, as probably we're actually winding down for the final time, because you operate both in carbon and for years in C++. Yeah.
你，总的来说，观察到了大家对它的反应是怎样的？因为你会听到很多诸如“哦，这不就是Rust吗？”或者诸如之类的话，而实际上它不仅仅是Rust，你也回答过这个问题。从你的角度来看，C++社区的反应是怎样的？普遍是“哦，不”，还是普遍是“哦，这太棒了”？是的，我原以为会招来负面评价，真的。
Have you, like what in general have you observed as sort of the response between, because you hear a lot of, you know, oh, it's just rust, or, you know, and then it's actually not just Rust and you answer that question. What's, from your point of view, been the reaction from the C++ community? Is it generally, oh no, or is it generally, oh, this could be great? Yeah, I thought there would be negativity. I really did.
我以为人们会说：“你怎么能对C++做出这种事？你怎么能背叛WG21像这样？”但事实完全不是这样。委员会里的人，你知道的，在发布之前就看过了。发布之后大家也都看到了。他们会说：“好吧，这可能对解决某些问题有效，因为有些问题确实是难以解决的问题。”这就引出了另一个常见问题：
I thought people would be like, how could you do that to C++? How could you betray, you know, WG21 like this? And that hasn't been the case at all. People from the committee have, you know, saw it before the launch. People have seen it since. They say, yeah, that might work for some problems. Because there are some problems, right, that are not tractable problems. Then it's another FAQ.
为什么不直接改进C++呢？好吧，如果你看看这些主要人物，就会发现他们都是尝试过改进C++的人，但有些事情是无法完成的，因为第一优先级是向后兼容性。这是一个不能打破的承诺。这是一个已经做出且无法搁置的承诺。这很公平。你知道，我对这一点毫无异议。但当你拿掉这个承诺时，它能带来什么可能？你现在能解决什么以前在C++中无法解决的问题？这正是我们试图找出的答案。
Why don't you just improve C++? Like, well, if you look at the cast of characters, it's all people who tried improving C++ and there's certain things that can't be done because the priority number one is the backwards compatibility. That's a promise that can't be broken. That's a promise that was made and that cannot be suspended. And that's fair. You know, I have no problem with that. But when you take that promise away, what does that enable? What can you now solve that cannot be solved in C++? That's what we're going to try to find out.
确实有许多问题需要解决。C++中有些地方使得编写编译器变得困难，但也让教学或日常工作变得困难。所以，如果我们不必与literally上世纪80年代的程序保持向后兼容，我们可以修复什么？这真是一个极好的问题。我知道有些人对性能有着非常具体的要求。所以你看到Functhona的博客了吗？我想就是他们，关于调用的。是的。
And there are things to be solved. There are things about C++ that make it hard to write a compiler, but they also make it hard to teach or hard to work in sometimes. So what could we fix if we didn't have to be backward compatible with literally programs from the 80s, right? That is a great question to ask. And I know that there are people who've got some very specific wishes around performance. So did you see the Funathon blog? I think that's who it was, about the calling. Yeah.
你知道的，哦，如果你想传递像int这样的东西，按值传递比按引用传递更快，因为它会进入寄存器，而如果你按引用传递，地址就会过去，而不会进入寄存器。而Carbon表示：它看起来像是一个值，但我们会选择更快的那种方式。如果按值传递更快，我们就按值传递；否则，我们就按引用传递。你知道，诸如此类的事情都是专注于性能的。对于需要
You know, that, oh, if you want to pass like an int, it's quicker to pass an int by value than by reference because it will go in a register, whereas if you pass it by reference, the address will go and it won't go in a register. And Carbon says it looks like a value, but we'll do whichever is quicker. If it's quicker to pass it by value, we'll pass it by value. Otherwise, we'll do it by reference. You know, that sort of thing is focused on perf. And for people who need
这一点的人来说，这将是一个巨大的、巨大的好处。而且有各种各样这样的事情，就是你们有不同的目标，有不同的优先级，所以你们可以做出不同的决定。我希望它最终能演变成一门我能够教授并且能够长期使用下去的编程语言。但即使它彻底失败了，我们也从中吸取了教训。是的，我想，你知道，我不确定这是否是最坏的情况。但其中一种情况是，它最终使C++变得更好，更接近我们大家所希望看到的样子。就像，我还没遇到过一个C++开发者会说：“哦，天哪，C++是我的最爱。它完美无缺，从一开始设计得就毫无瑕疵，没有任何错误。”没有哪个C++开发者没有让他感到沮丧的部分。我的意思是，你知道，你听过肖恩说过，我想在《编程要素》（Elements of Programming）一书的结尾，它甚至定义了C++的一个子集。而且有这样一句名言：“在C++内部，隐藏着一门渴望破茧而出的美丽语言”之类的话。你知道，这是一门我们都深爱的语言，只是这份爱旁边带有一些星号。我认为最酷的事情之一就是，每个人的星号都标在不同的地方。你知道，所以今天刚有人在讨论：“哦，你知道，不讲参数依赖查找（ADG）就无法教授运算符重载。”
that, that's going to be a huge, huge benefit. And there are all kinds of stuff like that, where it's just you have different goals, you have different priorities, so you can make different decisions. I hope it ends up with a language that I get to teach and that I get to work in for a real long time. But even if it totally flames out, there will have been lessons learned. Yeah, I think, you know, I'm not sure it's the worst case. But one of the cases is it just ends up making C++ a better language that's closer to what we would all like to see. Like, I haven't met a single C++ developer that's been like, oh, my God, C++, it's my favorite language. Absolutely nothing wrong with it.
而我说：“不能吗？因为我很确定我讲过，你知道的。”所以我们每个人都有自己的一点心病（bugbears），我们对它们有巨大意见、与之挣扎、希望消除它们，诸如此类。要说我们能让每个人都满意是绝对做不到的，因为每个人希望修复的东西都不尽相同。但处于这样一种状态：所有这些决定都不是束缚，我们不会被40年前的决定所捆绑，因为如果愿意，我们可以打破陈规。我们不仅可以打破语法（这相对微不足道），而且打破ABI（应用二进制接口）才是件大事，对吧？这样做是有代价的。
It's perfectly designed from the get-go. We made no mistake. There's no, any C++ developer has their sections that frustrates them. And I mean, you know, you've heard Sean say that, you know, I think at the end of the Elements of Programming book, it even defines like this subset of C++. And there's the quote, you know, like inside of C++ is a beautiful language waiting to get out or something like that. You know, it's a language we all love with some asterisks next to the love that things I think one of the cool things is everyone has their asterisks in a different place. You know, so someone was just talking today about, oh, you know, you can't teach operator overloading without getting into argument dependent lookup.
当然有。人们必须重新编译。但这也是有好处的。因为你不会无缘无故地为了好玩而去打破ABI。你意识到这样做能让程序运行得更快、体积更小或者诸如此类。然后却被人告知：“好吧，是的，但我们不能这么做。因为这会破坏ABI，而且人们不想重新编译他们所有的代码，他们也没有源代码，以及所有你不能打破规则的理由。”好吧。但如果我们真的这么做了呢？
And I was like, you can't? Because I'm pretty sure I have, you know. So we've all got our own little, you know, bugbears that we're like have a big problem with or struggle with or wish we could eliminate or what have you. To say we'll make everybody happy can't be done because everybody has a different set of things they wish they could fix. But to be in a position where none of these decisions are binding, that we will not be held to the 40-year-old decision because we can break stuff if we want. We can break not just the syntax, which is relatively trivial, but the ABI break is a bigger deal, right? There's cost to that.
如果我们打破了这些规则呢？这提供了一种自由。能够成为其中的一部分让人感到非常兴奋。是的。我的意思是，在CPP Casts的后期，你知道，我不知道那是第50集还是什么时候，在后期，杰森（Jason）每隔一集就会提起：“你在乎ABI吗？”你知道，因为我……你知道的。而且他开始收集这些回应，我记得要么全部、要么几乎所有人都说：“哦，不，如果喜欢的话，我们可以重新编译。”似乎这个问题……但随后我我知道马歇尔·克劳（Marshall Clow）做过演讲，展示了这其中的问题，而且外面确实有些人……你知道的，这对他们来说是一件大事。不过，通常做出决定的往往不是那些……
Of course there is. People have to rebuild. But there's benefit to that too. Because you don't run around breaking ABI because you felt like it. You came to realize that something would be faster or that something would be smaller or whatever. And then to be told, well, yeah, but we can't. Because it'll break ABI and people don't wish to rebuild all their code and they don't have the source code and all the reasons why you're not supposed to break things. Okay. But what if we did,
一线工程师，而是高层。一线工程师总是非常乐观，他们会觉得：“这大概只需要20分钟，没什么大不了的。”其实并不是这样的，这绝非小事，比如：“哦，我们没有那部分的源代码。”或者“没人记得我们给这个其他东西设置了什么选项。”或者“我们以为自己记得设置了什么选项，但显然没有，因为现在我们构建好后，它不像以前那样工作了。”这是一个非常有趣的状况。是的。
what if we broke things? And that just provides a freedom. That's very exciting to be part of. Yeah. I mean, towards the end of CPP casts, you know, I don't know how many episodes it was 50 towards the end. Jason was always bringing up every other episode, you know, do you care about ABI? You know, cause I, you know know and he started collecting these responses where i think either all of them or almost all of them were like oh no we could rebuild if we like it seemed like this issue like but then i know i know marshall clow is given talks that shows the issues of it and there are folks out there that you know it is a big deal for well it's often not the engineers that um are the one like the engineers like sure we could rebuild but it's often incisions that are being made um at a higher
是的，而且……我年纪够大了，我确实处理过连源代码都没有的东西。是的。我的意思是，对于某些人来说，ABI确实是一个真正的问题。我仍然认为我们应该定期打破它。不，所以有人在关于Carbon的演讲中提出了一个问题，关于每天改变语言的语法之类的。我对那个人说：“仁慈的。”我们
level than line engineers yes and engineers are so optimistic they're like it'll take like 20 minutes it's no big it's not it's not a big, like, oh, we don't have the source for that. Or no one remembers what options we set for this other thing. Or we thought we remembered what options we set, but obviously we didn't because now that we've built it, it's not working the way it used to. That's a fun one. Yeah.
应该成为仁慈的领导者，对吧？就像，这并不意味着因为我们可以打破规则，我们就要一直打破它们。但有些事情确实很有趣。第一个重大突破就是我们要打破一些C++的东西。我要改变一些默认设置，改变某些事情的做法，改变某些事情的拼写方式。而且，你知道，有些人为此快要抓狂了。没关系。你知道，我的意思是，Carbon里有var和let，其中var是带有一个可以改变的地址的东西，而let是不能改变的。他们会说：“不，你们应该把它拼写成const。”
Yeah. And like I'm old enough, I have worked on stuff that we didn't have source code for. Yeah. I mean, ABI is a real problem for, you know, some people. I still think we should break it regularly. No, so someone asked a question at the Carbon Talk about, you know, changing the syntax of the language every day or whatever. And I said to the person, like, benevolent. We're
是的。而且，我年纪也够大了，我曾经做过连源代码都没有的项目。是的。我的意思是，对于某些人来说，ABI确实是一个大问题。我仍然认为我们应该定期打破它。不，所以有人在Carbon讲座上问了一个问题，关于每天改变语言的语法之类的。我对那个人说，比如仁慈。我们
supposed to be the benevolent leads, right? Like, just because we can break things doesn't mean we're going to break them all the time. But some interesting things. The first big break is to say we're going to break some C++ things. I'm going to change some defaults, change the way some things are done, change the way some things are spelled. And, you know, some people kind of losing their minds over that. That's okay. You know, I mean, Carbon has var and let, and where var is a thing with an address that can change and let can't change. And they're like, no, you need to spell that const,
本该是仁慈的领导者，对吧？就像，不能因为我们能破坏规则就意味着我们总是要破坏它们。但有一些有趣的事情。第一个重大突破是我们要打破一些C++的东西。我要改变一些默认设置，改变某些事情的处理方式，改变某些事情的拼写。你知道，有些人对此有点崩溃。没关系。你知道，我的意思是，Carbon有var和let，其中var是地址可以改变的东西，而let不能改变。他们的反应是，不，你需要把它拼写为const，
you can't spell that let. Okay, yeah, we can talk about that. But the basic concept that we're not just tacking another keyword onto an existing declaration, but we're actually going to use a different keyword to declare it, that's in a way a break. And it's changing what the defaults are, because if you just declare an integer in C++, it's mutable. But it doesn't have to be that way. I mean, folks should keep in mind too that the people working on this language aren't just looking at C++. They're looking at many other languages. And if you look at the languages that they're looking at, sometimes the decisions they're making make more sense. Sometimes looking at
你没法那样拼写，let。好吧，是的，我们可以讨论这个。但基本概念是，我们不仅是在现有声明上附加另一个关键字，而是实际上要用一个不同的关键字来声明它，这在某种程度上算是一种破坏。而且它改变了默认值，因为如果你在C++中声明一个整数，它是可变的。但事情并非必须如此。我的意思是，大家也应该记住，参与这门语言开发的人不仅仅在研究C++。他们在研究许多其他的语言。如果你看看他们正在研究的语言，有时他们做出的决定就会更有意义。有时，如果只用
it just from a myopic C++ only lens would be like, well, why are you changing that? There's no reason to change that. Absolutely. So if you look at Go, if you look at Kotlin, if you look at Swift, if you look at Haskell, you know, people are looking at very, very modern languages and really quite old ones and getting some inspiration. But, you know, also some very bike-sheddy type questions are best solved by looking at other languages. So if you're going to have introducers for functions, if you're going to say keyword and then start talking about the fact that this is a function, here's its name, here's its signature, here's what it returns.
狭隘的C++单一视角来看待它，就会觉得，嗯，你为什么要改那个？根本没有理由改。确实如此。所以，如果你看看Go语言，如果你看看Kotlin，如果你看看Swift，如果你看看Haskell，你知道的，人们在研究非常非常现代的语言以及相当古老的语言，并从中获得一些灵感。但是，你知道的，一些非常琐碎、争论不休的问题最好通过参考其他语言来解决。所以，如果你要为函数引入关键字，如果你要先说一个关键字，然后开始讨论这是一个函数，这是它的名字，这是它的签名，这是它的返回值。
You know, what should the keyword be? It should be F for function. Should it be FN? Should it be funk? Should it be function? Should it be define? You know, and you can find examples in a lot of other languages where they've used different introducer words. And you don't just like have a vote and say, well, it turns out nine out of 10 languages abbreviated this way. But it is helpful to look across, you know, a wide history and say, listen, we're not the first people to face this problem. Let's take a look at some science out there. Yeah, for sure.
你知道，这个关键字应该是什么？应该是代表函数的F吗？应该是FN吗？应该是funk吗？应该是function吗？应该是define吗？你知道的，你可以在许多其他语言中找到他们使用不同引导词的例子。你不能只是进行投票然后说，好吧，结果有十分之九的语言都是这样缩写的。但是，纵观广泛的历史并说“听着，我们不是第一个面临这个问题的人，让我们看看现有的研究成果”，这确实很有帮助。是的，确实如此。
All right. With that, I feel like we've definitely taken you past. We're definitely over. It's getting dark. So we should let, we should let Kate go. Um, but thank you so much for coming on and spending. I know our listeners, they absolutely love the guest episodes and, uh, we've been mentioning your name. I mean, I can't count the number of times across episodes where we keep saying we got to have Kate on, we got to have Kate on. And I even apologized at the beginning of episode, I think it was 89 and 90 saying, we said Kate would be on, but she'll be on next time, we promise. All right, well, any any last plugs or things you want to mention calls to action before we let you let you enjoy your lakeside uh cabin which we are all jealous that you are at right now i would i would say to everybody check out the cpp north videos um at the
好的。说到这里，我觉得我们聊的时间绝对已经超出了。时间真的过头了。天都快黑了。所以我们应该让，我们应该让凯特离开了。嗯，非常感谢你来参加并花时间。我知道我们的听众，他们绝对非常喜欢嘉宾访谈节目，而且，呃，我们已经提到了你的名字。我的意思是，我都数不清在多少期节目里我们一直说“我们得请凯特来”、“我们得请凯特来”。我甚至在第89期和第90期节目开始时道歉过，说我们之前说过凯特会来，但她下次一定会来，我们保证。好吧，还有什么最后的宣传、想提及的事情或行动号召吗？在我们让你去享受那个让我们所有人都羡慕的湖畔小屋之前，我现在就在那儿。我会对大家说，去看看CPP North的视频吧，在
moment that we're recording there's only a handful up but by the time it airs it should be well over a dozen and that's probably more than you can watch right away so start watching some of those and uh and plan to join us next year. Awesome. Well, once again, thank you so much for spending your time with us. And enjoy the lake and the cabin. And we will talk to you sometime in the future, hopefully in person. All right.
我们录制的时候，上面只有寥寥几段视频，但等到节目播出时，应该已经有十几段以上了。那可能比你一下子能看完的还要多，所以开始看其中一些视频吧，呃，并计划明年加入我们。太棒了。再次非常感谢你抽出时间陪我们。好好享受湖泊和小屋吧。我们以后一定会再聊的，希望有机会能当面交流。好的。
Take care. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保重。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。